hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play look up I know
oh he already kills you he killed you
dead he killed you so dead oh I'm so
sorry about that
did I actually get the pus code to the
bus code that's a totally different
thing did I get the pass code to the
door to the basement because once I go
into the door in the basement then I'm
gonna go into the magical land of
happiness wonders and then I'm gonna
have lovely days all day long where I'm
gonna suck down on rainbows and ride
unicorns - oh man I didn't get the
passcode where where where as a passcode
uh hey I must've been something else in
the bar there because there's got to be
something and I've got this other key
that I still haven't used no no no no no
there must be something else
there's gotta be something right it
wouldn't just be nothing oh let's see
wait maybe there's a clue in here no
he's good sure as hell not us huh wait
no hang on uh um passcode was a sing
with a book which he chained plus a
passcode was this thing with a book
which he changed up every month okay
that's the clue I gotta go to the
library sorry the puzzles are getting
just a slightly more complex but me with
my giant super brain I'm gonna figure
this out so I might have something to do
with the book that was on the gore the
table in here
no in here no here no that's wrong
where's the library where the heck was
library wait a minute where was the
library no wait no no no no no no no
it's can't be right where was it for the
library
am I losing my mind I am I losing my
mind
where was the library I thought it was
to the left maybe it was maybe it was
all the way to the left I'm not losing
my mind I'm just going absolutely psycho
Barnes Atticus I really am The Crooked
Man
yeah Batman okay come on
yeah it was okay I'm an idiot okay there
must have been something in this see no
damn it oh I'm gonna be in this I'm
gonna be in this forever
there's got to be something here e to F
eater yeah
either earth there's gotta be some ears
gotta be there's gotta be shop in here
oh yeah oh oh Strange Case of dr. Jekyll
mr. Hyde he'd be on this shelf right yes
yes here we go okay we got it we got it
we got it
chapter one story the door mr. Utterson
the lawyer was a man of a rugged
countenance that was never lighted by a
smile colds Kantian embarrassed in this
Court backward in sentiment leaning it
along okay um there's more stuff here um
you can pause this if you want to read
this chapter one chapter two search for
mr. hi this is actually dr. Jekyll and
mr. Hyde if you've ever read it 1 to 4
October so 10 18 or 1 2 4 10 18 or 1/2
form and write some goes down
it's either 10 18 or 1 2 4 5 maybe not
chapter 8 uh chapter 10 and then the
year 18 there's a lot of numbers here so
I'll come on oh I don't know
god damn it
Omar you go okay piggy we're gonna go No
oh hi hi oh wow that monster did it
really uh yeah what did you expect that
went out okay what do we do what do we
do what do we do a little where to go I
gotta escape what why would you go in
here why would you go in here oh you're
such an idiot
oh yes is it up oh ah that's it that is
it I'm trying not to scream out of
frustration for the sake of my neighbors
what else happened what the hell
you boloney's khaki mushroom and I
didn't save I wasn't ready for that
what was I supposed to do he came right
after me it's quick like bunny manis
quick for Avenues head dangling around
like that knocking him between his knees
it's been hard to drag that thing around
mr. cooking man okay whatever that was
that was disturbing on multiple that guy
is like freaking what did honestly what
did you expect you dick it's not like he
was just gonna go away it wasn't a
figment of your [ __ ] imagination you
piece of crap I have the volume turned
up way too high Oh what do i do do I
jump in the hole oh oh you are so ugly
oh [ __ ] you so hard I don't
oh no oh no no no oh what do we do do I
jump in the [ __ ] hole ha ha if I drop
him down here yeah push him just push
[ __ ]
you've got you something happened my
neighbors are probably very mad at me
but I don't care
pant gasp what is that monster dude you
are such a badass man you don't give a
[ __ ] you don't give 10 [ __ ] you just do
whatever the hell you want you kicked
that son of a [ __ ] down that hole ah
Dan I can't believe such a thing exists
really really so there's no way it's
coming back now the room under is locked
tight um I hit one see what I see here
whoo I think I'll go in your room
oh man this is so ridiculous oh this is
so ridiculous this is so it's so
ridiculous no way
this is so unglue oh no no no no no okay
so I've got a whole bunch of numbers
here I'm sure that one of them must be
the pass code right that's the reason
why they stopped me ah
let's try 1018 first Boop must be the
wrong code okay and it's just a series
of numbers here um so you're one two one
two four five oh come on there's just a
bunch of numbers don't tell me I
actually had to read all that oh god man
that [ __ ] me I I thought I wrote down
every number that there was so let me
try something else let me look at it
again and decipher it with my big brain
power you all cheer me on I'm sure that
some of you have figured that out
already or some of you are pretending
and I've seen this game before played it
yourself though man and then OH
October 18th is 1018 so it wasn't that
the Carew murder case incident of the
letter bless we pool it must be this
might take me a while so everybody just
settle on down for a little bit
twenty-four five eight ten the missing
ones oh the missing ones three six seven
three six seven that's cuz another thing
before said that there were pages
missing
Oh totally man I did it oh three six
seven nine that's gotta be it
oh there's a smartness juice this
smartness juice going right through my
neck and I'm spitting I'm not even
hitting the stairs get on the frigging
stairs you bastard
I spit everywhere I spit it's just a
torrential downpour all over my thing
and I did I I'm not gonna cut that so
you all know that I didn't cheat or
anything I do not I did not three six
seven nine okay I know I'm celebrating
way too much but come on just give me
these small things I don't get these
very often okay okay
can you just could you just let me have
something thank you thank you very much
oh thank you very much I gotta use a
ladder to get up through the thingy but
it's out of reach how about you use the
ladder you dick I could use this to get
up to that thing well do it I spit
I spit everywhere guys got the key to
210 do I want to go to 210 smells Ron
smells run smells fresh like daisies
smells run it seems to be a big-ass
knife on that table can I have that I
would love to have that it's not small
at all it's bigger than I am oh I mean
it's not the size of the knife that
matters guys what I mean come on it
looks good it looks bigger and different
lighting it's cold in the place and
okay enough of those jokes I have done
that before
haha okay going to 210 and I'm assuming
that the ten categories over here yes I
am right so it must be all the way at
the end of the hall what awaits me in
here is something on the ground okay
looks like something was badly burnt
looks like something was badly broke was
this a photo looks like it was a woman
something under the pieces is it CC
scrap from a notebook good enough I
don't need her any memory anymore
I know she won't come back so I have to
forget everything good and bad so it it
so it is you get out of here bug so get
out of here bug I spit everywhere what
happened was that some of my memories
coming back
wouid settled down sheesh I'm exhausted
I guess I haven't slept much ah don't
sleep in this hotel man I know I
couldn't do that I'll never forget
not ever according to ball that makes me
a pansy
ah makes you psycho okay [ __ ] okay you
don't know this oh there you are David
I'm getting tired oh so tired let's go
to bed
no I can't find it there's lots of rooms
I can't go in so it might be in one of
those how about it's the one with the
crooked man in it seriously David are
you gonna tell this girl about the thing
oh it's nothing well I'm nothing but
[ __ ] you really should really leave
soon
why you may not believe me but there's
some kind of bizarre monster around I
found it in the basement
don't sound so nonchalant about it I was
attacked by it earlier you definitely be
in danger too I think you should
I'll show you my monster look I don't
like dark scary places either but
there's no need to tease me like that
I'm not a kid afraid of the bogeyman
okay or sorry but I'm not trying to
tease you I'm telling the truth there's
a horrible monster in its head like this
ah maybe you mistook something in the
dark you could be susceptible to seeing
things when you wander around in the
dark like this how about you go [ __ ]
yourself I saw a monster and if you want
to get eaten I'd like to think you're
right all right if you insist but be
careful okay what don't know you saw it
you kicked it in the balls I am getting
way too worked up about this story I'm
like personally involved in the
characters this guy isn't freaking idiot
but he's so badass I can't I can't help
but admire he's just like he's rock
solid he's like nothing's gonna faze him
nothing nothing fazes this guy he's like
a total badass you know what I'm good
for him he's probably gonna show his
badass Ria's her okay what what Oh down
there Oh [ __ ] did you write this leave
me alone
please leave me alone come to me I'm
waiting for you that doesn't make any
sense it's counterintuitive written in
sounds pretty inconsistent all right
high five buddy you did good there who
could have written this okay oh no it
looks different I dropped you down a bit
maybe you are [ __ ] varsity oh my god I
got a doozy what am I gonna do I can't
ooh
oh no damn it
oh [ __ ] you you're so weird oh you're so
weird
I don't want any I didn't say okay okay
I don't like you I don't like you what
am i doing what do we need to do can I
smash a bottle on its head it's heads
kind of low I can hit it oh man I'm
really trying to be quiet guys but it's
I'm really trying to be quiet but it's
not working it is not working it is not
working it's not working what am I gonna
do oh oh those sounds what do I do I
don't know what to do do we do I can't
go out so it's gotta be something in
here right we try smashing a bottle
against your head how about somebody
else
hmm smash huh guess I won't do much
alone what else can I do
well there's this glass or no what oh
[ __ ] oh yeah mom I was right there okay
you can't be Hughie's I'm gonna smash
every single bottle in here on your
freaking face oh hey that's allergy head
you BA how about some ideas yeah you
like yet hey boo ski
okay right now how about how about a
little ah come on
damn it what am I supposed to do
apparently bottles it's not good enough
barely bottled is not good enough what
am I going to do I don't know what's
gonna beat this thing I hate this son I
got to turn the volume that I'm just if
Jets deep down but I don't like being
here with it
I mean I'm gonna not in my hotel but you
know what I mean I mean I'm in here
playing this game alone with it you guys
aren't here to comfort me no no no no no
no no no oh come on
god damn it what do I do
uh maybe I smash it in no don't start a
new game
oh [ __ ] you god damn it get out get out
no I'm done with this part apparently go
[ __ ] you so hard [ __ ] you so hard that's
stupid I [ __ ] you and you won't even
let me [ __ ] you got it you get that okay
I'm done with this part I'll figure out
how to beat him later
good ah I can't even escape here okay um
we're back is bringing everyone okay
anyway so thank you all so much for
watching clicking and tasting for more
videos that I've done and I'll get past
this guy in the experts um see you in
the next part
bye bye